I wanted to brush my teeth the same time  every day which I'd never been able to  do I usually was like oh my breath  smells bad I should go brush my teeth  coincided with the fact that this  comedian Jim there's Jeff gaffris  I think Jeff something he was telling  this joke about his kid and that he  brushes his teeth while he pees yeah I'd  like to save some time and I thought  about that and I was like maybe I'll  give it a shot and so what I did was I  grabbed my toothbrush I put the  toothpaste on it before I went to go pee  the next night I did the same thing and  the next night I did the same thing and  then two weeks in I was like finally did  this I've made a habit of this rather  than like half hourly brushing  throughout the day and like forgetting  and remember it you know what I mean  like I was able to do it at the same  time every day and I did it while I was  big and that gave me how I've been able  to hack getting habits in